hi I'm Kevin Hart and I'm at Helm's
check out this sneak peek of our new
movie DreamWorks Captain Underpants it's
the story of a superhero I take that
back because he's barely a superhero
he's absolutely a superhero captain
under bad he doesn't have x-ray vision
he can't even climb a tree wearing a
cape does not make him a superhero yes
it does you know I'm not gonna argue
with you why don't you guys decide for
yourselves by watching this sneak peek
of DreamWorks Captain Underpants the
superhero let's try and leave and see
what happens that's an expensive door
mm-hmm from the studio that brought you
Shrek and Kung Fu Panda and Madagascar
hi I'm George beard I miss my best
friend Harold hutches we just make
comics and try to make each other laugh
and this old guy is mr. George
he's the worst principal in the world
ever since you attended his schools
you've been responsible for one prank
after another some of those must have
been really hard to pull off like that
tiger oh that tiger was crazy
ah I told you I would get you one day
I'm going to have you two place it's a
lady friendship
do something put the ping down mr. crup
or will hypnotize you my fingers you
will obey our every command I didn't
think that what happened this summer
comes I wish probably you'll get them
their greatest creation Captain
Underpants you can't actually fly I take
to the sky like an Oscar
wow he is super dumb Jiminy's now their
biggest problem
[Music]
based on the worldwide phenomenon hi
your class I'm the cool new teacher not
some scary guy with a secret evil agenda
guys I totally got this yeah totally
he's got it Kevin Hart Ed Helms Thomas
Middleditch knit crawl
when it's cut all together like that you
really get a sense of the scope
DreamWorks Captain Underpants pour so
you're trapped in some sort of invisible
box like prison is it okay that I'm kind
of loving this yes enough I will set you
free
Oh Mosley
you